foreign
you should deconstruct the cool things
that you see in life you know like when
you come across something that you
really like or that you think's cool so
in my case like I was writing a book so
how do I deconstruct bestsellers like
what's going what's going on there and
if you find a single example of
something it doesn't really tell you
anything but if you start to find
patterns then that's probably something
to pay attention to so I think actually
this is a great segue to kind of some of
these examples I was going to give so
let's say when I was riding Atomic
habits early on I was like how I know
what I'm trying to achieve I'm trying to
write the most comprehensive and most
useful book that's ever been written on
habits now I have no idea if I achieve
that and it's not really for me to
decide if we're being honest like I
don't get to choose that it did that
it's that's up to the readers to decide
is that a Mark that you hit or not but I
think that has to be the target you got
to start there otherwise you're never
just gonna stumble into that outcome you
know so like you have to like try to
intend to create something great
so how do we do that I looked at a bunch
of books not just about habits but also
other bestsellers one of the first
things I did was I went to the table of
contents for all those books and then I
was like how are these books arranged
and what you'll find is that
a lot of best-selling books they have
three they they break things into thirds
or it doesn't always have to be thirds
but they have like a clear structure
that the book goes through so that you
can look at the table of contents and
even though you don't know what's in the
chapters you know exactly where you're
headed as a reader what people don't
want is they don't want to open up a
book and feel lost feel like I have no
idea where this guy's gonna go with this
and it kind of feels like they're
wasting their time so a couple examples
you could do and I thought about these
but I didn't actually use these for
Atomic habits I could have had a table
of contents that was like habits of the
past habits of the present habits of the
future you know pretty clearly like
where that book's gonna go if you see
those categories in the table of
contents or
Power of Habit is another example if you
look at the table of contents there I
think he does habits of individuals
habits of businesses and then habits of
societies so it's like individuals
organizations societies and you can see
how he's kind of moving up the hierarchy
as you go through the book and another
one that I looked at I can't remember
which one of Cal newport's books it was
but it was either deep work or something
like that but he kind of like he had a
section on here are the the rules that
you need to follow and then there were
you know four rules or six rules and so
each one of those got their section in
the book and the point is just there
needs to be a clear road map for the
reader and if you start looking through
what other bestsellers are doing you can
start to think about how to transport
that onto your own experience
another thing I did was I tried to look
at what is the average chapter length
for a lot of these books you know when I
signed the book deal
the publisher and the editors I was
working with which I love my publishing
team by the way but they were kind of
encouraging me to write longer chapters
like six thousand or eight thousand
words and I was coming at this as like a
blogger you know like most of the things
I wrote were like 2 000 words or 1500
words and eventually what I settled on
was most of the chapters were between
two and three thousand words and that
felt like the right length you know yeah
and just for folks to have a reference
point I mean one printed page what would
you say it's roughly like 300 yeah I
think most of my chapters were about 10
pages so yeah
so 300 words yeah if it's a 3000 word
chapter maybe it's 10 or 12 Pages
something like that
so yeah figuring out the length and I
started to notice other things that like
novels would do or
books that weren't necessarily
non-fiction
they the chapters are really short and
there's kind of this momentum that gets
into it like it kind of gets you
flipping pages and it's easier to keep
churning through the chapters and so I
wanted to have that kind of chapter
length
I actually think Atomic habits is still
a little bit longer than I was hoping I
just couldn't figure out a compress it
more my initial manuscript for the book
was 700 that was like 712 Pages or
something
and the finished version of the book is
like 250 so you know yeah I compressed
it by you know 66 or whatever so it's
it's much smaller than it started out as
which I think is good because I feel
like a lot of books especially business
books they could have been like a blog
post or a 20-page paper and they get
turned into a 200 Page book so I wanted
to do the opposite I [ __ ] hate that
it's the worst it's so bad but I
actually think if you look at books that
sell really well a lot of the time
they're like 180 to 220 Pages they're
they're actually a little bit even a
little bit shorter than what I ended up
hitting so these are all examples of
deconstructing you know best sellers of
what's going on probably the most
important place to do this is with
titles so I have a spreadsheet of
hundreds of titles for books that I the
way that I did it was I said I'm only
going to look at books that have sold a
million copies or more that's what I'm
trying to achieve so let me just see how
many books I can find that have done
that
and quick question tactical question did
you do that through
access to Nielsen book scan
asking a publisher for help with
Publishers Marketplace I didn't have
access to book scan because I was just a
I was just a poor blogger who was you
know trying to make a book so I didn't
have access to any of that stuff
but what I did was I just did tons of
Google searches yeah and usually what
happens is that when an author hits a
million copies or four million or
whatever yeah yeah they'll let you know
yeah they let you know and so there's
all kinds of stuff or you'll find like
if you just search a title and then copy
sold
there's New York Times articles that
profile an author and they say you know
that book sold six million copies or
whatever so it was just a bunch of leg
work like that
anyway I put together that spreadsheet
let's say I got like 150 titles or
something and then I started to look for
patterns so what format do all these
titles follow and I think I ended up
coming up with they're about six I won't
be able to remember them all off the top
of my head but the most common format is
the blank of blank so the Power of Habit
the life-changing magic of tidying up
The Power of Now the power of positive
thinking
the subtle art of not giving a [ __ ] the
blah blah so it's always the blank of
blank and that's a very proven the war
of art it's a very proven format and the
psychology of money like we just keep
going on and on and on there's so many
examples like that and usually what
people do is they take their topic and
that's the second piece and then they
take some type of descriptor and that's
the first one and ideally you're
combining things that are not usually
combined so
like the life-changing magic of tidying
up so tidying up is the topic of the
book but now you're telling me that it's
life-changing and what you find is a lot
of these best-selling books they have
some element of contrast in the title
there's something that's unexpected
about it so even the another common
format is you just take and this is of
not giving a [ __ ] right you don't
usually exactly like yeah the f word is
actually the least subtle thing right so
like there's this interesting contrast
between the two another common format
this is the one that I use for Atomic
habits is you take the topic of your
book and then you layer on some kind of
unexpected descriptor before it so
I'll get to Atomic habits in a second
but like extreme ownership by Jocko so
the idea is you take ownership and
responsibility for your life but you do
it like in this extreme way it's not
just like a regular idea of taking
ownership or Cal Newport deep work
you're doing work but it's a special
kind of work it's not the normal type of
thing that you're thinking about so
these are these are just examples there
there are a couple more patterns that I
found but and then ultimately you got to
decide like which one makes the most
sense for me you know which one feels
like it's the best fit for my book but I
started to generate a bunch of titles
and which one can you live with forever
yes titles are really tricky because
they need to pass a lot of filters they
they need to be about like they need to
cover what the book is actually about so
like in my case it needed to actually
talk about habits I think it's important
to have some element of contrast so like
in my case Atomic has multiple meanings
it can be tiny or small so your habit
should be easy to do it can be the
fundamental unit in a larger system so
like atoms built into molecules and you
know systems versus goals is like a big
part of the book it can be the source of
immense energy or power so I think if
you kind of combine all those three
meanings you get the the under the like
Big Arc of the book which is you make
changes that are small and easy to do
you layer them on top of each other like
units in a larger system and then you
end up with these kind of powerful or
remarkable results as a as a byproduct
so for all of those reasons I kind of
felt like atomic was a great word to
describe it
but it needs to so it needs to describe
what the topic is it needs to be
interesting and compelling or like a
little bit different sometimes good
habits are like a little bit weird in a
sense like nobody was really using the
phrase Atomic habits before the book
came out you know it wasn't like a way
that you would describe a habit you
might describe it as small but you
wouldn't describe it as like Atomic it
had been good habits
I just for people out there right you're
going to be competing with the entire
internet yes for search results I
actually think a lot of titles fall into
this Pitfall which is they use a phrase
that is commonly used and you want a
phrase that you can like own in the
reader's mind
you know like you don't want to be
competing with yeah all the other things
that use the phrase good habits
you know four hour work week is a good
example of this nobody really used that
phrase before the book it was like a
little bit weird yeah in the sense that
it wasn't part of normal conversation
and that allowed you to own it
it also had that element of contrast
you're like man I work for 40 hours a
week you're telling me I can work for
four you know it's like it's the
surprising thing another example that
might be like Rich Dad Poor Dad you know
so that book has a great time of
contrast between the between the two
so
it needs to be like something that you
actually want needs to cover the topic
of the book it needs to have this
element of contrast like there's there's
a lot of filters for it to pass and
that's why coming up with good titles is
hard